okay so i asked luke and kyle to dig up
the three best
steroids you know now that we're
now that we're at an appropriate age and
we found out
some of the sway boys was actually on
steroids mm-hmm
it's okay it's okay for us to take it
you know people wouldn't shame us with
all the trend use
we can't we can't get in trouble for
wanting to take this stuff
yeah that's fair so
and we are serious by the way we are
going to start taking steroids
a list of major anabolic steroids and
everything you wanted to know about them
[ __ ] all right here we go hgh
okay so on the list
the the one the three that are on the
list the first one is trend balloon so
it's just trend
that's where you get trend cough from i
know about dianaball
little d d-ball so there's a [ __ ] ton of
steroids or deca i've heard
i've heard deca i've heard those two
um let's look let's look at tren because
i still don't understand tren
but i want to know what is sarms because
i see a lot of sarms [ __ ] now
for some people you can buy it online i
think it's like technically legal i
don't know if this is true or not and i
don't want to end up on the [ __ ]
steroids
youtube channel like every time we talk
about steroids i mean yeah
youtube channel from some steroid guy
that's like they were wrong about this
and it's like i know
i don't [ __ ] take this [ __ ] i'm just
wondering what is sarms
and because i saw someone talking about
it how he bought it online
but they're really dangerous or
something and that's what i think the
tick-tock guys were on i don't know um
well for okay so with tren
considering the most effective steroids
by bodybuilders trend
is dividing two types acetate and
enantio what the [ __ ] does that mean it
helps you
lose big amounts of body fat and gain
big amounts of muscle mass
uh it will give you some aggression too
yes
that's what i'm looking for i need some
more anger it's just turning you into
the [ __ ] angry emoji i'm not angry
enough i should have told that guy
when you ask for gas no
[ __ ] you dare you confront me you take
trend just to have a [ __ ] just happen
just to have some semblance of [ __ ]
push over stand your ground
baby gary you know what gary no i won't
have that memo for you by end of day
today it's
44 30. i'm going home it's 44
30.
what's their favorite side effect of
taking trent well i
i finally have no problem telling my
brother i will not be coming over on
sunday
sunday is my day my brother keeps asking
me for money and i finally told him no
no more so do you work out no no
i don't no no
holy [ __ ] taking trend just to [ __ ]
just to have the confidence to want to
cast yourselves how are you doing just
ending it
i'm good not asking how are you back
or even being able to say the right
thing yeah you know normally in that
scenario i would say
uh you know not much how are you
not much you oh
with my tail between my legs not anymore
not on this none of this trend stuff
i confidently can answer that question
with good
you know i'm good i'm pretty good
pretty good i'm pretty good
all right wait what was what was the
on the charms debate heats up over
sarm's fitness
supplement an fda warning letter and a
rate of california companies offices
highlight issues concerning the
supplements some feel are a healthy
substitute for steroids okay so it's a
supplement
okay uh what's in it
they aren't currently approved for use
in humans [ __ ] yeah yeah
let's go let me get a lot of those oh
let's go
what the [ __ ] is this yeah is this like
is it a fitness world is this like horse
training material like what do they use
this for
to grow lizards
um sarm's crazy name sounds like sars
androgenic steroids are known to
increase muscle development but are
accompanied by a host of undesirable
effects for men
it often means acne breast development
oh let's go let's go i want some milkers
and enlarged prostate and shrinking of
the testicles i got testicle to give i
can give up some tests
it doesn't sound like side effects to me
yeah oh you're going to make my huge
balls a little bit smaller
and you're going to give me a [ __ ]
great rack yeah a pair of jugs
[Laughter]
i'll slap around my own titties
[Laughter]
one major side effect of psalms is it
completely erases genitals so the
private area is just completely smooth
okay it also has been known to give
users big
juicy milk wagons that'd be crazy just
erases your penis it gives you gigantic
boobs and you're ripped as [ __ ]
it gives you big fake tits like the
definition
it gives you big big bolt-ons yeah
the definition on them is just crazy too
like everybody thinks they're fake like
those are implants right like nah
these are these are my naturally serums
crafted breasts
they found that only half of them
actually contain sarms about 60 percent
contained
ingredients different from what was
featured on the label nearly 10
of the products tested didn't contain an
active ingredient of any kind
holy [ __ ] oh these are sarms that you
can buy online
so 10 of sarms bought online
it doesn't even contain anything you're
just buying water
or just bad [ __ ] awesome straight
placebos dude
are you on those placebos i'm getting
bigger dude i swear
i don't know man life-threatening
reactions
including liver toxicity having occurred
in
people taking products containing serums
storms also have the potential to
increase the risk of heart attack and
stroke
long-term effects on the body are
unknown yeah it's all right man
yeah that's that's the main thing is
that like it's gotta put a lot of
pressure on your heart but then so so
does drinking
you know so you like it as well yeah i
might as well at this point no but it's
like
i feel like we we're pretty fast to
judge people that take steroids and
stuff because of like
the heart risk and stuff but like
alcohol has to be one of the most
poisonous things your body and
everyone's totally fine with that yeah
well
i'm i i don't judge people to take
steroids i'm just you know
i'm not i'm not crazy enough to take
them
i'm getting on sarms yeah i'm getting on
the water sarms
can i get water flavored sarms please
it would be fun to do it for a year just
to get kind of jacked up you know
yeah but then you just lose it all yeah
and then you get soft skin and i would
do that she turned to a baby afterwards
it like it's like it's like the fountain
of youth you get really like roided up
and beautiful and then
you just turn into a soft little baby
again you become emotional
yeah you get benjamin button disease
after that
[Laughter]
back to square one literally the
fountain of youth is right there it's
arms get yolked for a year then turn to
a baby